welcome back to the dr drew little hour
here to help answer every question that
you've ever wanted to know about
fostering and adopting is the author of
the amazing new book pop culture stories
tips and the importance of adopting a
dog is author victoria lilly schaefer
she's also the daughter of paul shaver
and we have a very special review of
this very special book you're going to
want to see this take a look
we've been reading this book called pup
culture
culture it's from victoria lily schaefer
paul shaffer's daughter hey where hey
dumbbell where are you going anyway it's
fun stories and tips about the dogs and
what you can do when you adopt a swell
dog hi boys come here come here yeah oh
there he is sully come here and say
hello see these these are my dogs
and i think you'll enjoy the book
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome animal rescue advocate
victoria lilly schaefer
[Applause]
let's see how this goes
he might be really friendly or express
like small man syndrome i don't know
which way it's gonna go nice to meet you
thank you this is roo
roo say hi
hi rue how are you i like to not come in
too hot yeah good um i also try to not
make eye contact right oh so great
really yeah just just let them come to
you that's the best we've had some dog
snap this week in my rescue for being
too
feeling the feeling of cornering can be
very intimidating i know you kind of go
in real hot
and i also like to do a little
so you all remember how i smell do you
want to take a sniff
[Laughter]
now your dad is someone that i've known
a little bit from afar and yet had some
insanely memorable moments with paul
schaefer yes
hi
and was he a dog person were you always
a dog person what's it like in your
phone how did we get here
it has been a long journey to get here
my parents did not grow up with dogs so
they weren't exactly dog lovers did you
always want one i wanted one so badly
and when i was 12 i got my first
computer it was a flower power macintosh
computer you know those bubble computers
and um i found this site called
petfinder.com oh sure and it was over
from there i would send my mom email
after email of dog listings and one day
she just
caved because she was probably annoyed
by all of my emails
yes i did and we had two dogs growing up
but still we were we weren't a dog
family we had dogs we loved them dearly
but it wasn't until rue came along that
we really
started to become a dog obsessed family
um because rue was very shy she was
found in a dumpster we all felt for her
there she is
and she was so shy she was not well and
she made a very uh big recovery she's
still shy but she's like the baby of the
family i douglas was adopted from a
shelter at eight weeks old
and i still see the
like the nerves yeah with with him i
there's i i think he has a little bit in
his breed and i think he just saw some
things when he was younger that will
always make him just a teeny
apprehensive they're traumatized they've
got you know even at eight weeks old
they've been through something they
don't know the side of the road
i think he had been tossed from a car oh
and it's just heart i can't i can't i
can't even say it out loud because it's
so it's horrible so all of my dogs and
the dogs that come through my rescue pop
culture rescue
um have a little cork i call it a cork
it's not an issue you know it's not
something to be judgmental about you
just keep it in the back of your mind
that maybe they're a little shy or they
don't like feet by other dog he hates
feet like if you just stretch out it's
like he saw a ghost so he was probably
unfortunately kicked or something before
i adopted him it's amazing how they can
be so forgiving of humans after some
human out there has put them through
such trauma so what is a good way to
foster a dog i would say go straight to
your organization but beyond that what's
your advice totally um it's a great way
to meet people and the community is so
amazing check out petfinderadoptapet.com
social media is amazing just search for
your local rescue we need fosters so
badly because without fosters we can't
pull more dogs off the streets or out of
shelters
so if you have a little extra time and
you can open your home up it is an
excellent way to give back
and when you foster can you figure out
if you're a match can you date
definitely sort of have that kind of
chemistry exactly if you will and then
help the dog find a home like when you
foster is that it are you stuck or it's
like no no you too can find out if
you're a match and commit then if you
want adoption is a massive commitment
everyone needs to realize you are
committed to this dog for 10 plus years
yeah you want to make sure you know
you're vibing it's the right fit so you
get to date yeah it's it's speed dating
okay so do you have any
memories of david letterman when you
were younger absolutely we used to spend
every summer at his montana ranch and
that's
probably my first introduction to
animals even before the dogs because he
had so many horses my dad would have to
give her some space dougie
everything's i know where this is headed
um uh we would have to get on a horse
every summer my dad would have to put on
the chaps and the
jeans and dave had the best outfits ever
just full
uh cowboy boots leather chaps the best
everything
david letterman in chaps thank you i
needed that
thank you
perfect
that's so awesome well guess what
the ever so wonderful paul schaefer is
actually here and we're going to go to a
quick commercial break and when we come
back
there's actually going to be a dog
adoption taking place on this very stage
come back
[Music]
you